welcome to get cooking in club where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and we're
joined by Jenny hi everyone
today we'll be continuing our recipe to
help dinner winner make the most of
their implementation and of course we'll
be continuing with our gluten-free
recipe now that we have cleaned our
workspace of the identified allergens
we've got a few moving pieces with this
recipe so let's quickly review where
we've been and where we've got to go
[Music]
in the last episode we introduced the
application called dinner winner they
collect recipes from users all over the
world review them and award prizes for
the recipes delicious enough to repost
on their app the recipes aren't supposed
to but they might initially contain
personal information of the participants
and that information cannot make it to
the judging or the final publicly posted
recipe card so there's some work to do
to make sure the automated
classification puts the right data in
the right spot at the right time
fortunately we've got a plan this will
be a four step process dinner winner
will first create cloud storage buckets
to be used as part of the quarantine and
the classification pipeline they would
need to create a cloud pub/sub topic and
subscription to notify between the two
cloud functions then they need to create
the two cloud functions one that invokes
the DLP API when files are uploaded and
the second that uses the DLP API to
inspect and classify the files and move
them to the appropriate bucket then
finally upload some sample files to the
quarantine bucket to invoke the cloud
function now let's start by creating the
cloud storage bucket but before we can
even do that we need to set up our
environment create or select the GCP
project and make sure billing is enabled
then head over to the api's and services
and enable API s4 cloud functions cloud
storage and cloud data loss prevention
api's now that we have the API is
enabled let's enable the correct
permission so that our App Engine
service account can connect with the DLP
API for that we will open the I am an
admin page in our project locate the App
Engine service account and edit the
roles add project owner DLP
administrator and DLP API service agent
and save next we'll grant the DLP
service account the permission that it
needs locate the DLP API service agent
and add a project viewers role to it now
we are ready to get our cloud storage
buckets created we navigate to cloud
storage and create them remember we will
need three buckets one for sensitive
data one for non sensitive data and the
last one for all the files as they come
in name the buckets as you
but remember it has to be a globally
unique name once we've created all three
buckets you should be able to see them
all in the storage browser now we're
ready to set up our cloud pub/sub topic
and subscription let's navigate to cloud
pub/sub and create a topic provide it a
name and hit create then to create a
subscription corresponding to the topic
click on new subscription provided a
name and create at this point we've got
the setup in place for dinner winner and
we have two more steps left but now that
we've got our process and our
contaminant-free environment let's get
baking what a recipe this gluten-free
thing is no joke but it's critical to
have an understanding of what goes in
and what stays out it's a delicate
balance but we're halfway there stay
tuned for next week when we get dinner
winner to the finish line for their
implementation automated classification
pure we come for more information about
alternative approaches do check out the
articles link in the description below
and if you're hungry for more be sure to
LIKE subscribe and catch up on all the
ways you can get cooking with cloud
you